brooklyn nine nine two by ten
hey yo why don't you go ahead and hit
that like button you're gonna like it a
lot i guarantee a man's warehouse i want
you to go ahead and subscribe and click
that notification bell to get notified
when our next reaction for brooklyn nine
nine is up and while you're at it won't
you go ahead and support us over at our
patreon page over there we do full
length watch alongs where you sync up
with the time code for brooklyn nine
nine and we cover a bunch of other shows
as well lastly thank you to your boys
over at prepper but it ain't down these
highlights yes son of a [ __ ]
any sign of our bogey negative are you
sure our guy's gonna show my ci said he
walked this route exactly the last three
days
and a bottle of rum presents god you're
bad at being santa
the pontiac
duck judy
mary judy mr doug judy
[Laughter]
are you wrinkle socks
greasy
nypd stuff where you are
come on santa why are you so fat gotcha
oh no
yeah
drains in the air hey rosa merry
christmas girl shut up
take a good look kids this is what
happens when you're naughty
[Laughter]
it's a good visual
i present to you the seventh wonder of
the world doug judy aka the pontiac
bandit boiled at last
[Applause]
pontiac bandit water to be cotton it's
my moment you are not to enjoy it i
can't help it i'm proud of you like a
son of me a white crispy son how would
that even work am i adopted no your
mother's just really pale
almost invisible
[Laughter]
you don't want any info on a local
burglary ring perhaps not good enough
testify captain how about a guy who
makes fake credit cards negative you see
that judy no matter what you say you're
going to jail giggle pig y'all ever
heard of giggle pig god
what do you know we're listening the
plot thickets boyle this is bad i
thought our parents were just having a
casual fling but presents is like old
people third base no that's rubbing
butts together but this is very close
they may be getting serious
[Music]
what if it's a romantic book or like a
picture of the two of them in a frame oh
or his and hers pajamas the kind that
dissolve in your mouth ew what
so this is where all the tape went
i got to put up these pictures my
daughters drew
and i need some because i cut my oh god
go to the hospital and give 100 bucks to
some doctor to give me the exact same
tape i don't think so
[Laughter]
i asked the captain what qualified as a
gift and he said anything i spent money
on then i realized my time is worth
nothing
no
i'm making a scrapbook of his
professional highlights newspaper
clippings police reports pictures it's
got every moment of his career
from rey to z
nice
i'm not happy with the title either but
my backup was keep holding on huh i say
the only way we make a deal with doug
judy is if he can give us the top guy
tito ruiz i can give you tito ruiz oh
come on
he's a lie guy bro there's a point you
have been a lie guy to us before
he texted me last week needs some cars
to deliver his product i said no because
drugs are stupid suffer weed in sex
pills man has knees
rosa rosa rosa i can't think of your
last name baby
[Laughter]
i can see why you have such intense
daddy stuff with him oh yeah the guy
without a daddy is the one with daddy
issues explain that logic
four-star hotel like the oneida 200 in
food no minibar or alcohol but i get to
go crazy on candy and nuts agreed
oh one last thing diaz has to be nice to
me i know how to call me big sugar
i'll never agree to that no i'm in let's
do this big sugar
[Music]
he never leaves my sights love it
pontiac bandit and jake pb and jay right
again
reunited and it feel
[Laughter]
four-star hotel room you happy we should
settle down here also now if y'all
excuse me i'm gonna go freshen up i'm
feeling stunky
no
would you just relax okay stop being so
paranoid i'm playing ball
i got you
if you'll excuse me
don't trust him you're gonna let the
criminal have all the fun
all right fine
i'll have one lobster thermador extra
thermador on the side i have no idea
what i'm ordering
you know how we take this to the next
level robes robes
oh no
no
do it
okay we just unwrap it we see what's
inside and we perfectly re-wrap it our
parents never know what happened ugh
lord ah boyle men will notice that
wrapping paper oh you're dabbing me
really hard you know what this is taking
too long just scooch yep pooch
whoa catwoman you are amazing how did
you do that i always open my gifts in
advance so i can rehearse my reactions
and nail those christmas morning candids
check it out the wonderment
just be loving it
your dad got my mom
a digital scale that's bad oh
your dad might as well have circled all
the parts of my mom's body he didn't
like with a marker you did that to me
should we do a gift exchange dinner
tonight with both our parents great idea
maybe she'll slap him in the face and
never talk to him again sparkle surprise
for real
oh that's me salad trying to eat healthy
i hear that body's a temple whoa whoa
whoa whoa putting your fingers in my
fancy face i'm supposed to escape using
a lobster squeeze the lemon of my eyes
so i can't see stab me in the jugular
with a claw and then shove the tail down
my throat so i can't scream for help
tito wants to meet up great tell him to
meet us over here we'll get him a
lobster in a row
i mean no let's go catch him in the act
has captain holt ever told you about the
brooklyn broiler yeah burned down 12
buildings in crown heights captains told
me about it many times
you flamed out
dirt bag
well i think the captain may have made a
mistake what
i was doing follow-up research on the
case for a fun where are they now
section and i don't think the brother
set three of the fires he was charged
with i gotta tell the captain do you
think he'll be upset probably not i mean
maybe next year you can do a collage
about low points in his marriage i know
you're being sarcastic serge but i
really do love making collages
hey yo what's up my man doug judy who
are they how's my bodyguard selena
we doing it on a dl he's an amazing
lover
[Laughter]
where are you going thunderstone to
steal the car i jacked the rides judy
holds my tools
fine then you'll have two minutes only
need one
that was tight
i played them like a boss next like a
bounce i'll pop it huh
yeah and i pull it yeah pull it back put
it back hard
yes i love the way you dance doug judy
it's like french kissing got it jam it
in there and move it around wildly i
gotta ask peralta do the ladies enjoy
that technique
okay let's go
looks pretty easy fairly inconvenient
double date kind of like a
fun christmas four-way right well
a very sweet sentence
a digital scale
lynne boyle you're a horrible horrible
man
you went way over our price limit and i
love it
it's gonna go so great in the guest
bathroom what lynn and i are moving in
together
okay well this is wonderful
but i am needed elsewhere so
take off something
i was just looking through some old
files and i think i may have found a
mistake in a closed game maybe if i'm
remembering correctly and i i could be
wrong on this it's the brooklyn broiler
what that dirt bag flamed out ages ago
why were you looking at that case she
was making you a gift not a gift snitch
didn't cost me anything just my
worthless man-hours
bring me the brawler's file i'll look
into this mistake actually the evidence
is part of the scrapbook so i have to
leave the whole thing fine i'll look at
the relevant pages but as for the rest
i will not peruse
[Music]
a little bit what do you make here don't
worry about it oh cool cool coco coco
[Laughter]
i'm the bus and this is my place and in
my place people know they shouldn't ask
dumb questions
got it
yeah i got it i tried to tell them t
though
all right let's talk deets
what the [ __ ]
no we gotta go right now go go
[Music]
damn it
damn you young judy
i'll never forget you dante thunderstorm
oh
ooh
you have the right to remain doug judy
anything you dug or judy can be used
against you in a dug of jesus huh oh
i'm preoccupied by someone who will
remain nameless
the gift i'm referring to is you
pointing out my mistake
do you know why i don't accept kids
because you're so evolved you don't need
material things because i don't like
brown-nosing oh yeah oh
you told me to my face that i made a
mistake and that's as far from
brown-nosing as one can get i respect
you for that now i have a gift for you i
have the complete brooklyn brawler files
he was given three life sentences and it
should have been two
will you please help me figure out who
set those other fires ooh
more work
sarcastic nobody thought that not for a
moment
i thought you'd be in an awful mood why
would i be upset when i've never had
more purpose in my entire life
our parents say they're in love but we
both know that's just their old brains
disintegrating we need to break them up
for their sake
i forgot how clammy your hands are move
unaffected
nice house of gucci
actually i'm a little disappointed in a
hotel how do you mess up the omelet it's
just a flat egg
about my escape this is my associate
kyle
oh
[ __ ]
at the hotel home service waiter yeah
yeah yeah
[Music]
you're like this is the guy's name
good catch
[Laughter]
good attention to detail
i know how hard that was to make that
choice and let him get away now it was
an easy call i know how much this task
force means to you you mean so much it's
been so stressful and went so well
i cannot stop smiling oh how do people
do this with their faces
[Music]
she's attractive she's she's attractive
that's more attractive than you
yes absolutely more attractive than you
i mean that's a that's a big list right
there
people less attractive than me is a
shorter list it's longer it is yeah it's
a short one see it's comments like that
why
you're on the most attractive list oh
sexiest man alive paul rudd
now i'm ready to film this review all
right guys look at that volume
yeah it's like flat you talk about me
being being sexy jesus look at you yeah
attractive man i've got some gray hairs
here no those are those are attractive
too i've learned people say don't don't
hide the gray
oh then why do i dye my hair once a week
i mean you know hold on to that dream of
youth my friend
all right guys
well
john
yes tell me everything
you loved about
one of the storylines just one okay
um
i
very much appre i mean it's hard not to
start with the back and forth between
doug judy and peralta and the trio of
him and rosa i mean it's so true john
it's already building into something
that's like it was fun the first time
and now after seeing this i'm like i'm
excited for next season when the next
doug judy episode comes up you know how
did he get kyle in there i have no idea
kyle must have a lot of jobs
like i saw him like
every kyle i've ever seen is like a
there's a super white boy it's the
whitest among kyle ryan some of the
whitest names yes so when i saw him i
was like i've never seen a guy i've
never seen a brown guy listen brown guys
bizarre
that's weird
that is a great detail catch
then my mind just started going like did
they intentionally put out like ethnic
casting for this cop this is their way
of diversifying in this episode yeah
they're gonna cast increasingly ethnic
actors for increasingly whitely named
characters so then when we showed up at
the beach i was like i know that face
so i know that face
from my racism
my racism and has i got a race r
right
yeah race r
race r anyway
yeah man that was funny that was [ __ ]
funny
[ __ ] fun and not too many efforts in
a row but then we're gonna get
demonetized funny yeah that solves the
problem
quite and superlatively humorous
solving the problem there john i mean
it's easy for doug judy to lure someone
in like
jake i get i do think he likes jake yeah
he keeps sending him these messages
when he gets away
escape
was it was the caper gotta what's the
phrase
the caper got away
slipped
slipped through the fingers slipped away
slipped through the
racks
the criminal
fled nash
i don't know what it is i'm looking for
something looking for something witty
but it's not coming to me
this one seems a little bit more
elaborate though
like how did he get kyle in there
how did uh
i mean he like perfectly planned when
the dumpster truck would
burst through
who did he have an extra phone hidden up
his butt or something how do you know
about the gps how do you well yeah i
mean second he put it in i was like
judy's got to find it but he must just
be that good or something yeah there's
always that thing of he's one step ahead
somehow it's hard to tell
but they're so funny together and i like
that this season's been showing
different shades of rose's personality
letting stephanie beatrice get to have
more fun than just dry delivery yeah
yeah well you can't have too many of
that character on one show yeah she's
fun and uh
what else happened oh my god that whole
thing would like
um
uh
chelsea peretti
oh royal yeah
boyle's parents that is so gross
so disgusting
is
a digital scale a good present though
no it's a terrible present you don't
give a
woman a scale
[Music]
what you give her is a 21 day detox
you give her a weight watchers
membership
paid for
you give her a peloton one time a girl
got me um uh cologne
i smell better like
what are you trying to tell me
i was giving she had a good point yeah i
know yeah she was right i was a smelly
man
your natural musk is very uh
alluring smelly or smelly sure oh god
it's
just a off-putting scent
[Laughter]
it's so gross we're steeped in it now
but i'm used to it
habituated over the years i'm used to
you mister
coffee and no cigarettes
yes
hence that's half as bad so you
described johnson
coffee and no sugar coffee and no
cigarettes john
that's good
next time you see me i'm going to be
noticeably like fruity smelling or
something oh man in new york there's a
lot of jewish a lot of people from
brooklyn oh my god there's so many
people who are
coffee and cigarettes oh yes it's the
[ __ ] animal cigarettes
our second most viewed
state
in all of our demographics you're all a
bunch of smelly
smelly bums yeah take a shower or some
matter with you i'm walking here while
drinking my coffee and smoking my
cigarette
get out of my way while i jaywalk hurry
cab
yes
i like the idea that in new york you can
hail anything you need that's
stereotypical enough my coffee here
thanks
yeah man and uh so yeah gina their
parents doing it that is so gross i
could not oh my god
that'd be like if my mom was doing
olivia's dad yes yeah right you would be
your own uh step siblings i actually had
a never mind
in case someone tries to steal my idea
i had an idea for a romantic comedy
that's a very similar situation have you
started writing it i did but that was
years ago are you start writing let's
read it pull it up on the computer
interior
dawn
bedroom
all four of them wake up and wonder how
they got here sorry structure it's
interior bedroom done and uh your dawn
bedroom who starts with interior what
the weather's like interior brand
inside greg's body
yeah that's that was bad and that's why
i stopped writing the script because i
went to go read a book about formatting
her said that you're like something soft
this doesn't look like any other script
i've read that i apparently didn't read
too closely enough to glean the
structural dawn bedroom interior
i like to put my uh slug lines at the
end of every scene so you imagine the
scene your own way and then you come to
find out what the location time of day
and otherwise was i remember your your
first line started with moments later
yes
but we haven't seen any interior moments
later doug enters night time
meanwhile exterior
dialogue
night time
uh
i wish we saw more of their parents
though
yeah i mean it would be nice to have
seen them more than once before this
episode i think like it's a funny
plotline but uh those are two good
comedic actors great comedic actors and
we we've only gotten like two minutes in
total of screen time with them yeah like
literally like a scene per episode
they've shown up yeah yeah
uh yeah they're both funny and then of
course
amy me and holt and terry kissing
ass the way she does
i like the way that one unfolded
ultimately i let her kiss my ass you
know what i mean
my smelly ass
well you know just take a thug duty
shower you know blow dry your
undercarriage and you'll be ready to go
that's not how it works man you gotta
take some medication for what i got
you gotta get that
weapons grade it's a deodorizer it's a
condition and it just delouse you with a
fire hose everything i'm gonna get
treated just
don't judge every morning i walk in and
greg is jamming air fresheners down his
pantaloons i make jokes about it and try
to lighten up the situation but man
my god everywhere i go that's why i
don't go out hmm pandemic was great i'll
just go to new york
yeah then you'll be free
water and bagels hey
can i go
where's the giant rat let me ride it
down the street
20 stories no elevator
oh yeah that'll that'll that'll work up
the stink yeah you walk up 20 stories no
elevator three grand for a studio
a hundred square feet
somehow it's got a bedroom in it
new york is
incredible
you could skateboard a cockroach down
the street
ah i know really big yeah
never seen that honestly i've never seen
someone skateboarding
i've seen a picture or two and heard
many a horror story from folks i i've
spoken to who lived there a while in not
nice parts of town
or like that cockroaches are bigger than
some of the rats like whoa
olivia once went to a hotel and then
when we checked in in the bathroom was a
dead
cockroach
i'm trying to be realistic about this it
was like
i want to say like that big from my
thumb to here it was massive
and dead
and i couldn't pick it up i just
couldn't i was like i just can't do it i
just can't do it like called the guy
from at the front of the hotel i
wouldn't either and i was like there's a
dead cockroach here uh i don't really
want to touch it and
and uh
he showed up and all we expected was for
him to pick up the cockroach and throw
it in the toilet and then he's like
we'll show you a different room we were
like really
not bad you're like yeah it's policy i'm
like what that's bizarre this one i
don't expect much
that's awesome i mean that they would at
least be willing to i mean
on the one hand you're like well it's
still in the same building they're
probably ruined
but uh that was awesome that they would
do that i know right and that they had
extra rooms to accommodate you yeah they
charged us twice
for the roach extermination
you just let it stay there as a warning
to all the other roaches you wouldn't
have had to pay should have gone on yelp
and said something
three stars found a roach
but they helped they helped us can you
imagine what i would have done to that
motel
if i just took a photo and put that on
yelp oh man they'd never do business
again yeah you would have shut them down
i could have shut them down without one
photo sent a whole bunch of people
reeling into unemployment
bring their lives crashing to us only
like two people who worked there oh it's
like a mom and pop they can say and
suffer for this having a shitty service
and not cleaning up the dead cockroaches
you think when you clean up a hotel room
for people
yeah that would be on your face maybe
the cockroach right next to the toilet
should be picked up
or yeah yeah removed
what if we got in there it was alive
that would be worse
yeah because then you would befriend it
and skate down long beach
hey man i mean people if you could
overcome that skin crawly thing people
raise cockroaches and apparently they
yeah much as sickbest you know they're
kind of smart
they're sick they're disgusting they
will outlast a song
disgustingly so probably i think you
have to be disgusting to to outlast
today to die even you mrs love it even
though
all right guys well thank you so much
for being here i want to thank john for
guest starring today
thanks for having me yeah no problem now
you wanna you can stick around for more
and shoot other stuff with me if you
want what yeah man
if you want i'll do like one more uh and
also
bye
[Music]